let's leapfrog from the first decade in  the Academy's history to write a current  chapter who wins the Oscar for  cinematography let's find out from two  new faces who are both nominees  themselves for their expert pretending  in the Graduate Katherine Ross and  Dustin Hoffman  welcome kids the nominees are listed  here and the idiot cards are out there I  don't think we need them you don't need  those you mean you memorize what you've  got to say yes well if you can't read  that's the way I guess for the best  achievement in cinematography the  nominees are Burnett Guffey for Bonnie  and Clyde  Richard H Cline for Camelot  Robert Surtees for dr. Dolittle Robert  surtees for the Graduate and Conrad Hall  for in cold blood the envelope Burnett  Guffey for Bonnie and Clyde  thanks everybody that helped me do it  that's all I can say